[Music]
i have lots of things to talk about um
but i'm happy to take questions
um
in the middle and at the end uh let me
just get the q and a thing so i'll see
if there are questions
so um
i want to tell you today about
how we can use recent advances and not
so recent advances in machine learning
in a context that may be a bit different
from
what you typically hear about
you hear about the use of
deep learning in computer vision natural
language robotics things like this
and today i want to tell you about
scientific discovery
but actually it's also very much
connected to questions about how humans
understand the world
how they build a causal understanding of
the world
and how for example children
explore and play in order to learn
so it's it's i think interesting both
from the point of view of how we can
build robots with these same abilities
or machines with the same abilities
and as a tool for scientists
to help them in in discovering and
understanding um their uh nature and
their field
okay um
so
let's let's consider the
uh iterative discovery process that we
find in in many sciences where you can
do experiments or where you can validate
hypotheses more generally
so how does this work um
we typically already have some data or
maybe we don't and we need to do some
experiments to
collect data about a phenomenon that
we're trying to understand and study so
with the data that we have in hand we're
going to build models
analyze that data
and then using that model we're going to
generate new hypotheses
to explain that data and sometimes
there'll be several hypotheses to
explain the data i mean that's the
typical case we don't fully understand
how the world works
so there may be multiple explanations
then we're going to
design experiments to try to
discriminate between these hypotheses to
test
and then of course we do the experiments
and we collect more data and we go over
and over
so so that's that's the kind of setup
um that we are interested in uh studying
and seeing where machine learning can be
useful
and roughly can be useful in two main
places
so one is on the right side to model the
data
and capture the different possible
interpretations for it
so the explanatory hypothesis
and on the left side we're at the bottom
here to design new experiments which is
actually a different question but can be
derived from a good model
that captures the uncertainty about the
model
right
now in sciences uh you know we have more
and more
data more and more machines that can
measure things in a digitized way
we have sometimes quantities of
experimental results
spread out through
many many papers
and it's very difficult for a human
brain to manage all that data
and and so i think that there's a huge
opportunity to accelerate science using
using machine learning and the kind i'm
going to talk about today
one of the ways to think about this how
machine learning can help
in
scientific discovery is to help
deal with something that looks
intractable and that a human brain is
pretty good at but machines can help
with which is a sort of
problem of searching a needle in a
haystack so what is the needle in the
haystack well that could be
a drug that could cure some disease or
the needle in the haystack could be
a simple theory that could explain the
data
the problem is in both of these cases
the number of possible
things we would like to consider is just
huge
and
there may be several good solutions but
typically the fraction of good ones
might be very small and in fact often we
want to get all the good ones so in the
case of drugs
we want to find if there are multiple
good molecules we want to find you know
all of them if possible because maybe
some of those candidates will fail later
or
we can combine them and in the case of
theories of course we want to know if
there are multiple theories that explain
the data because if they disagree
then one of them is wrong and i mean or
maybe all of them are wrong except one
or something and so this is crucial
important part of crucial importance for
science
so
um instead of thinking of this search
problem as an optimization problem just
typically what many people have done in
the past
um
what i you know the angle i'd like you
to
think about is
it's more like an exploration
so
when you do
optimization you might find
one maximum if you're trying to maximize
something but maybe there are other good
maxima maybe there are local maxima that
are almost as good and this may be
important information
so
if we want to find not just one solution
but all of the good solutions are you
know many of the approximately good
solutions what can we do we need
something different in optimization we
need something that will produce a
diversity of solutions
and as i said in the case of drugs this
is important because some of those
solutions might not work out at the end
maybe
the drug looks good
on a mice but it's going to fail in
humans or it looks good on single cells
but doesn't work on my system
yeah so that's why we need diversity uh
of of candidate solutions uh to to
propose um
we uh we have for example in the drug
discovery process uh uh
a kind of funnel of um
gradually more precise ways to evaluate
candidate solutions so maybe initially
we do some computer simulation what's
called in-silico screening
and it's going to be an approximation of
reality that's not very good but it
allows us to filter
uh
you know get rid of many possible
molecules that clearly are not good and
then
we take
uh
you know those that seem good according
to this criterion and we're going to
test them in a more stringent way maybe
with uh
um
in in uh in vitro
uh experiments on on cells and so that
you know that's going to already get rid
of a lot of these possibilities because
well the model is is that we use for
screening in silicon might be wrong
um but then you know cells are not the
real thing uh those that seem to do well
in cells we're gonna try in
uh
animals uh maybe mice or something
and um and that we're going to get rid
of a lot of candidates here maybe you
know the the drug looks good on single
cells but it breaks
it breaks havoc on on the whole body for
some reason some interactions just some
type of toxicity that we haven't
envisioned and similarly you know we
take we're going to take the ones that
work well on mice and i'm going to try
them on humans in clinical trials
and of course these as you go to the
right these are much more expensive
um
so
so we need to learn a a
a way to to propose these candidates
that's going to generate a diversity of
candidates that's that's the bottom line
here
okay so we're going to look at methods
like active learning that have been uh
proposed and bayesian optimization that
have been proposed to do black box
optimization so what is black box
optimization
um let's say you've got a function f
that you don't know but you can call it
so you have an oracle you do the
experiment
and you specify an experiment x you
produce you can you get an output y
um
so now the question is find x's that
that you know give you the
the best value the largest value of y in
the case of optimization
but i'm going to suggest we want to do
exploration so we want to have like all
the modes of the function f or
all the high values somehow that are
diverse
and
and also we're going to be typically
able in many scientific experiments to
not just try a single experiment but
maybe
tens or hundreds or thousands or
millions of experiments in parallel
because uh for example in biology
we can um
we can program cells with
to to generate different kinds of
molecules
and uh because you know you can have
many many such cells you can have tens
of thousands or hundred thousands or
millions of these different programs
corresponding to different
uh sequences or molecules that they
could generate so so they're you know
more and more like for example uh
robotics is being used in
experimental sciences to paralyze and
accelerate the the process so so there's
also the question that we're not going
to generate a single candidate but a
bunch of candidates a batch
and we want diversity inside that batch
um so uh there's a connection between
what i'm talking about
something in the reinforcement learning
banded literature called thomson
sampling
which has been used now for um a couple
of decades in in active learning setup
where
you
uh you consider a dejan belief about say
what f should be
and then
you
um your model of the world and um and
you simple according to that that
posterior belief
and then you know given a particular
belief you try to find a solution that's
uh optimal for that belief so if you
think of the different modes of f as you
know beliefs of where are the where's
the where's the gold
um
one belief might be to focus on one of
those modes and of course when you focus
on nodes you want to pick the peak of
that
all right um so
so there's a long tradition of active
learning in machine learning at least
from the 90s and it was initially
designed
um
to
um
to to help speed up learning
where we have a fixed
list of examples that have not been say
labeled by a human like images that have
not been labeled yet
and we want to choose
which image we should ask the oracle the
human to label
so that we will learn as quickly as
possible by asking the humans as
as few times as possible
um
so so that's that's good and there's a
lot of literature and the general idea
is uh
and the kind of heuristic is
you want to pick the image to label that
has the most uncertainty according to
the current model since the
the the the image that the
current model uh
wouldn't know how to label properly
but i'll come back to this question of
uncertainty it's more subtle than that
but there's a problem with this approach
when
the list of possible things we could ask
the the oracle to label
is exponentially large so when we have a
million images to pick from we can train
some sort of neural net that predicts
uh how interesting or how uncertain that
might be about each image but
uh if it's not a million but 10 to the
60 which which is something like the
number of uh
small drug like molecules that we could
design there's no way we can
even in a computer compute a score for
each of them and then pick the ones that
look best so we need something else what
we need are georgia models we need
some learning system
that
has sort of embodied the information
about the relationship between the x's
and the y's
and then is going to sample
new x's that correspond to high values
of y
um you know good candidates and um and
so so this is what we're going to do and
and one heuristic reasonable thing to do
there which which is connected to
constant sampling is to say
we're going to
uh
pick
we're going to try to design our
judgment model so that it samples
uh candidate experiments
with a probability proportional to
some some kind of score and and i'll
come back to what that score should be
but uh it's
how much information
the
experiment will give us the information
we care about so this is called the
estimated information gain or the
expected information gain
i'll come back to that
all right so again um
what are we trying to do in inactive
learning and uh we're gonna
the learner is not just gonna be trained
in a supervised way as usual
it's going to be
participating in
deciding what the data it sees should be
so there's connection to enforcement
learning but it's a more limited setup
and um
and so we have this feedback loop
between the learning
and uh and the experiments where the
learner can not just model things but
also decide
what to try next
and of course each time we get more data
we can retrain the system and come up
with a new policy for generating the
next batch of candidates
so let me now
go a little bit deeper into
the question of uncertainty because what
i said earlier wasn't quite
right
um if
if you think about the problem of you
know deciding which images are most
interesting to label if you have an
image that is
uh
so ambiguous about what it content is
that even humans might not be able to
say what is inside the image
there would be a lot of uncertainty
about what the right label should be but
maybe this is not the kind of
image we want to ask humans to label we
want to ask humans to label
images
that have the property that if we get
that label
we're going to improve the model
so
to to make sense of this uh people who
have distinguished two
different
types of uncertainties the allegoric
uncertainty and the epistemic
uncertainty so
the alliatoric uncertainty is due to uh
uh ambiguity that's uh you know in
nature that's that's unpredictable
uh uh
that's due to the the the joint
distribution between x's and y's
um it's just noise randomness right
lack of information
so
so that kind of
uncertainty you know is not going to
change if i
uh observe more experiments so the the
error i make
here is not going to improve
um
at the limit if i if i see you know
infinite amount of data of this noise it
doesn't really help me to
to model the phenomenon better
what helps me is reduce epistemic
uncertainty so epistemic concern t is
the part of the error
that is reducible that is due to the
model itself that the model is wrong
that the model
lacks knowledge that um how you know we
didn't see enough data
so so clearly the you know this this is
what we want to
estimate and reduce
okay now there's an interesting special
case in between which is somewhat has
some both properties
uh think about a chaotic system so it's
not noisy so it
technically it's not electoral concern
like if i redo the same experiment with
infinite precision
i'm going to get the same answer
however
it's kind of unlearnable uh in general
that either it's just too difficult for
a learner to
capture
that
it just looks like noise even though
it's not noise it may look like noise
and so it's not going to be possible to
reduce our error by seeing that kind of
data
in general i mean you might be lucky and
i have a very simple chaotic system but
in general
um it looks like noise and so
we should treat those like if they were
elevated or constantly or like think of
um how much better our model is gonna
get after we do the experiment that's
sort of what we care about
okay so how could we estimate this
epistemic insurgent because as i said
this is what we want to reduce so we
want to be able to evaluate what it is
for a candidate experiment we haven't
done
um so so there are many methods uh and
i'm going to mention a very simple one
that gives us a glimpse of you know
general strategy
so we could have for example what's
called an ensemble of neural nets so
this is a very popular method it's very
simple
and uh and it kind of state of the art
in many ways
so what we could do is we could train
say 10 year nets on the same data
but with different initialization
or we can introduce other sources of
differences between them maybe like they
have a different subset of the data but
actually it works even just with the
random initialization
uh we could randomize the order in which
they see the examples for example so
they
that also will help
but we can actually train them on the
same data
and what happens is that those different
neural nets will end up learning a
different function
um so that's interesting right so what
we have here is
all of these neural nets they do well on
the data so they are plausible
explanations for the data
but they produce different answers of
course they can't all be right
and we don't which one is right if
anyone is right
but we can measure how they differ from
each other we can measure their
disagreements and that is going to give
us a clue and a quantitative way to
estimate a systemic concern so it's very
simple like measure the variance on the
output
uh or some some similar metrics
so so that's that's uh
you know
simple uh you know we we're going to pay
a price in computation but it's it's
related to a more say principled
approach
um that's the bayesian approach to
machine learning maybe you've already
learned about
where
think of a neural net where we consider
not just the inputs and the outputs to
be random variables but we considered
the parameters of the neural net to be
random variables so in what sense are
they random well in the sense that we
don't know what are the right values for
these
uh these parameters
and then same thing you know what i said
with n symbol of neural nets we don't
know which one is correct
so
in principle we could get to that
episodic incidency by measuring the
disagreements between
all of the ways that we could set these
these parameters
that are compatible with the data that's
called the bayesian posterior and i'll
come back to that
okay
so now
let's put uh
these things together in a sort of
active learning loop where we're going
to have a world model and we're also
going to learn a policy that decides on
you know the experimental design policy
as we call it that's going to decide on
what the next experiment should be
so we see on the right is is is the real
world or some oracle that's going to
give us some some y's given x's so x
specifies an experiment and why are the
measurements we make
um so using the xy pairs that we have
seen in the past we can train our world
model
and uh as i said we also want to be
careful that we're not just training it
to make a single prediction but also
give us some notion of uncertainty for
any particular tax any particular
experimental design how uncertain are we
that the outcome should be
why
once we have trained our world model
um we can train a generative policy as i
mentioned earlier
uh which you can also think as a as a
you know from a reinforcement learning
point of view
and that policy is going to be trained
with some kind of reward function that
we're going to be able to compute with
our role model for example how much
epistemic uncertainty is there in a
particular experiment x
and we might want to use this as a
reward
so that we train our policy to sample
uh configurations of experiments that
have a high reward that have a
high uncertainty because these are the
kinds of experiments we want to have
and that's a setup that corresponds to
in reinforcement learning we call
model-based reinforcement funding
because
we don't train the policy directly on
the data we get from the real world
we train it
by allowing it to interrogate a model
that we train from the data so there's a
sort of interaction
here
and it's useful because maybe
experiments and especially in scientific
setups
but also if you think about robots
experiments are expensive i can't try
everything
and uh and so
i'd like to collect all of the knowledge
that i have gathered from the data
into something that is cheap to
interrogate which is my you know in
silico model my my like little computer
program
that has um that represents all the
information i got
from from the data
and then i can train my policy
on this and i can interrogate my
internal model
as many times as i want it's just
computation so computation in general is
going to be cheap compared to actually
doing experiments
okay i see already some questions
um
so
one question from samuel uh do you think
that a good solution to the problem that
there are too many possible
configurations of the experiments
is to reason over structured low
dimensional space zes instead
um yeah i i do think that you know uh
being a deep learning person that
representations are super important and
that that is going to be part of it yes
um
but
what i'm talking about here is more like
the auto loop like what are we trying to
do then we can think of how
our model is going to be structured how
our policy is going to be structured and
um
and then we can we can exploit
that to do better on both fronts
um
so
mirafan asked in estimating uncertainty
we still assume that the setup is id
well that depends if it is id then we
can assume it if it's not we don't need
to assume it maybe the data is
sequential
um and then we we learn those
conditional distributions for example of
the
next outcome given the previous outcomes
or something like this so it depends on
what you're trying to do you don't need
to make
these assumptions if they are wrong you
shouldn't
um andrew asks would there also be
uncertainty in the different world
models we could arrive to and how could
we deal with modeling bias okay these
are great questions so in fact as i said
in the context of active learning
um
estimating the uncertainty in the model
is super important because this is
really what's going to drive a lot of
the
um
the the experimental design because we
want to do experiments that are going to
be informative that are going to improve
the model so we need to know where the
model is lacking and that's the
uncertainty um how we could deal with
modeling bias well that's
that's a great question too uh often in
science
and in uh lots of work in machine
learning we make abusive assumptions
about how the world is so we maybe you
have strong parametric assumptions the
reason we make these assumptions is make
calculations easier maybe we have
analytic solutions to the epistemic
consumption like we can get the bayesian
procedure analytically or something and
that could be interesting to do but
of course there's a big danger that
introduces biases that make the
the policy really learn something quite
wrong
um
so
the strategy that i prefer
is to
have both
a a model you know family of models
that's broad almost non-parametric
that's you know or think of like a
really large neural net that essentially
can learn anything
but that we also use knowledge that we
have
maybe some kind of inductive biases some
things we know like i'll talk about
causality for example
and and use that in order to structure
the model so that
we're gonna get
something that generalizes better with
less data so we we're going to have both
the best of both worlds
all right and then uh mirafan asks given
that we want to make the data human
consumable with exploring numerous
strategies experiments at what point of
time
should we cast doubt on the previous
findings
that we use to create the model
uh why should we cast any doubt on the
previous findings i mean unless the
experimental setup was wrong
maybe it was not exploring in the right
space but but if we use
model-based reinforcement learning like
model-based approaches all data is good
you don't need to throw away anything
what is wrong maybe the policy that we
trained before so you know policies that
we're
trained based on some data
you know may turn out to be wrong once
we see more data and we see that
uh we have the wrong model or you know
the policy didn't work well but i think
if you go for a model based approach
there's no need to throw any data
except if the experiment itself was
somehow wrong
and even in that case if you can specify
in what ways it was wrong it might still
be useful data
okay i'm going to move on
so so let's consider this objective
of
for the for the experimental design
policy
to sample experimental configurations x
with a probability proportional to some
function which we're going to call a
reward function because this is like a
kind of like rl
so the idea is that we want a sample so
let's say r here the reward is
the the epistemic uncertainty or
something like this that's like how many
how much information do we think we're
going to get by doing this experiment so
there are many ways of doing that
but but let's say we have some ways
based on our model and and some math
so we end up by say maybe training some
machinery that that computes r for any
given x where x is an experimental
specification
so and we we can set it up like scale it
you know set it up so that it's going to
be a positive quantity
uh that is going to be high large for
you know good good experiments and those
that we want to do and and and close to
zero for useless experiments
so now we can say let's let's how do we
design a joint model or a policy that
will sample
x with probability
r
normalized so divided by z where z is
the normalizing constant of r
because this is going to very
naturally sample
the modes of the distribution
uh the high values that's what we want
so there are classical ways of doing
this uh monte carlo mock of chain
methods
and um in fact they can be considered
like the gold standard for doing these
things
uh but there are some issues that i'm
going to talk about
first they are expensive computationally
because you have to run this markov
chain where you try many possible
configurations and gradually modify them
sort of to improve them
but with some some noise
um and also a problem called mode mixing
that i'm going to explain but that
practically means it's not going to find
it might not find that many good modes
it might like miss on some of the modes
maybe most of the modes
so let me explain what's going on let's
focus on the figure in the bottom here
um so let's say the uh the curve here on
the bottom is the r of x or the
distribution we'd like to sample from
and what mcmc is doing is uh random
moves local moves
um
that prefer to go towards higher
probability configurations or
lower energy so we use the term energy
here to mean like
a normalized um
minus probability so p is proportional
to e to the minus energy that comes
physics
so uh when we deal with unnormalized
probabilities like the word some often
we we take the log of the probabilities
and we get these minus energies
so
this is just a
a way to talk about unnormalized
probabilities in the way that's
numerically nicer
okay so
so um
what's the problem with the mcmc
approach here
besides the fact that it's guaranteed to
converge asymptotically as the number of
these moves goes to infinity which is
good but first of all we you know
ideally would like to converge faster
maybe you know after five moves or ten
moves you're not going to get that with
mcmc in general
but the other maybe uh more even more
tricky question because it's not just
about computation is that
if the modes are highly separated from
each other like they're separated by
regions of low probability like in the
bottom we have
two modes on the left two modes on the
right and they're kind of separated by a
low probability of flat probability
region
the problem with these uh what i call
deserts of probability is that crossing
those deserts is exponentially unlikely
because you have to make a lot of moves
against the you know what the system
wants to do like it wants to go back to
the things that have high probability it
doesn't want to go to the right
and and if you know if it's only one
you know lucky move to the right that's
enough to cross the desert is a small
desert then you're good but if it's 20
moves then it's going to be you know to
the power 20 less likely to do that and
so so this is called the problem of
mixing between modes
okay
um
now
mcmc methods are
leaving some money on the table let me
explain why and and refer to the picture
on the top right
so here we have these three modes let's
say that we have already visited with
our markov chain or whatever method so
we already know that these three places
get you high values of the reward
low energy
um but there may be other places and and
the game is how do we find those places
and the way that mcmc finds those places
it you know it's wherever it was before
maybe at one of those modes it makes
random new moves and hopefully it gets
to one of the good places
uh by trying to climb you know towards
higher probability
configurations
but if
okay but we could do better because
if we use machine learning to extract
information from the places we visited
like we've seen these three modes oh
they kind of line up on a grid so maybe
there's also a fourth mode at the
intersection here where i put a question
mark
so this is using data that we have seen
already about the relationship between
x's configurations and their their
energy or their their anomalies ability
with their reward
and and then generalizing to these new
places so this is basically what genetic
models do
if you train gender models on like
images of uh faces which are like a very
small tiny fraction of all the possible
images they will generate new faces
um so so we can use gentleman models to
learn from that data and and generate
new candidate
uh modes basically um that we can just
test and measure the reward for for that
for them
so this is an idea we uh explored in an
europe's paper of last year
um the approach we call it uh generative
flow networks
and
um
and we then wrote a bunch of other
papers so there's a large uh paper on
the a lot of the math behind it that's
on
uh let me let me explain and a bunch of
others i think
well i didn't put them yeah so
a bunch of others since then um um so
let me try to explain a bit what this is
um
so it's something in between gender
models and reinforcement learning
um and can be used as a fairly general
purpose tool for probabilistic modeling
um so the idea is is what is you know
what i stated we want to learn to sample
from a distribution for which we know
a
animalized probability like a reward
function but we're going to do it in a
structured compositional way so we're
going to assemble these objects like
an experimental specification
through a sequence of steps that's very
important
it's the sequence of steps that allow us
to construct very complicated
objects and very complicated
distributions
um and we cannot like deal with the fact
that maybe there are many sequences that
lead to the same object so there's a
sort of non-autoregressive aspect to the
generation process
as part of building that model that
samples we also can learn what we call
flows that give the name to the method
that correspond to
marginalized quantities uh like
the partition function the sum of the
reward
and uh and probabilities of uh you know
partial constructions
um or other
quantities that are generally
intractable that are that these neural
nets are going to be able to estimate
um so to be more concrete
[Music]
think of a neural net
that um takes a partial specification so
let's say the specification is given as
a graph
this is this is the case we studied in
the first paper where
the objects of interest the
specification is a molecule like we want
to propose a new drug
so so these could be represented as a
graph say
um and so we're going to have a we can
learn a policy that generates
new graphs but the way that it generates
new graphs is by a sequence of actions
for example
taking on a partially constructed graph
initially maybe it's an empty graph and
adding an edge like we see in the figure
so how does it add an edge well
the neural net sees the graph as input
maybe it's a graph near that
and it outputs uh through softmax
a discrete choice of things you could do
like add uh you know node number four to
node number two or something like this
um and so it outputs a distribution over
the possible actions in that context
then you're going to sample from that
and that's going to tell you what to do
to this partially constructed object to
move the next stage
and that sequence of choices that
constructs the experimental
specification
and you're going to do it again and
again
and there's maybe a special action at
some point that says oh we are happy we
think we have a good molecule and we
exit that process and we hand you this
candidate experimental specification
like this graph
so we have generated a graph through a
sequence of steps
so um
we're going to learn that policy we're
going to train that neural net using a
particular training objective
that's going to
be such that when we train you know
enough we're going to converge to
the thing we want that is sampling
these objects with probability
proportional to uh the reward function
that we're given
um
okay so
uh there there is uh
maybe complicated slide here but before
i do this i see maybe there's a question
um can you please talk about how
generative active learning with the
world model is different from the theory
of active inference by carl frista
uh no i don't think i'm going to answer
that question
um
but their call is
is is using uh variational methods
uh or at least uh you know talking about
directional methods and and there are
like very strong connections between uh
what i'm talking about in variational
methods so
yeah
but but i won't have time to to to go
into that detail
um umar is asking is there a link
between g flow nets and denoising
diffusion models yes uh there is
um
so
uh it will be a little bit long to
explain especially i would need to
explain the noise and diffusion models
but let me try very quickly so in the in
the noising diffusion model we do is we
we have a process of corruption
of
an object that's that's given in our
training set and uh we you know through
go through multiple steps of corrupting
it and we train
a uh a reconstruction a stochastic
reconstruction uh
model that for each step given a
partially
corrupted thing tries to
un denoise it that to you know uncorrupt
it you know generate something that's a
plausible
source of that you know before we did
the corruption
um so that's how the noising diffusion
models work
and they're trained
in
and the g flow nets do something very
similar except that they learn both the
process that like noises and the process
that that generates the object so here
in the figure
that we're seeing uh i i showed you
about this pf it's called pf for forward
so it's it's the policy
it's the thing that constructs the
solution from scratch but actually in
the g-flnet we typically train a
backwards
uh policy if you want that you know
given a
uh
a a
constructed object maybe you know an
image or whatever it is
uh we're going to sequentially
go through the same steps as the forward
process but backwards so we're going to
like transform it into something simple
like an empty graph in the case of those
graphs um so yeah they're nice
connections
um
all right so the flow analogy
you look at the picture on the right i'm
going to try to explain it
so the picture on the right is supposed
to illustrate all the ways that we can
construct an object like a specification
of an experiment the x's here
of course there's usually an
exponentially large number of ways so
this is just a cartoon to illustrate
some concepts
so we start say in a initial state which
is always the same like the empty graph
s0 on the left
and we're going to make a choice
according to the policy to go to either
state s1 or state s2 in the figure
so maybe you know we can add you know
this edge or that edge or you know
something like this
um
and then
you know you you can do it over and over
right in each state your multiple
actions you can take that bring you to
the next state and sometimes the action
like this t for terminal brings you to
one of the terminal states which is
you're done i have the object i'm
finished
and the um the blue things there uh you
can think of the some water flowing
through
pipes and we're going to take the
probability of the
the actions the policy
to be uh proportional to the amount of
water going through an edge so
starting from
s3
the probability of going to s7 is going
to be you know the amount of water going
from s3 to s7
divided by the amount of water going
through s3 which is the amount of water
going through s3
to s7 plus the amount of water going
from s3 to x3
so you know we just take the sum of the
flows amount of water
going through these edges
um as a normalizing constant to get a
probability
of choosing you know one of these
actions corresponding to one of these
next state transitions
um so what's interesting about these
flows is that they are like unnormalized
probabilities and they tell us a lot of
interesting things so for example
uh you know just by sort of intuition
you should see that the total amount of
water flowing out of s0
should be equal to the sum of all the
flows entering into the terminal nodes
and we know how much flow should go into
the determinant modes this is the reward
like this is the animalized probability
that we were that we want to get for
each of these x's
so
uh the way that we're going to train
these g formats is such that uh we're
going to learn a function that assigns
to each of these edges and each of these
nodes an amount of water and a float
such that
actually at the end of the day we're
going to be able to read off the total
um uh the sum of all the rewards uh over
all the possible terminal states in the
initial state of course
we're going to get an approximation
because we're not going to be able to
visit all the terminal states there's
going to an exponential number of them
but we're going to get a kind of
prediction of of that partition function
and we're also going to get a policy
the forward policy that tells us how to
go from one state to another state by
you know normalizing the flows on the
edges and if we normalize the flows in
the other direction we get a backwards
policy that tells us you know starting
in some final state uh you know sample a
trajectory that could have led to it and
that's the backward trajectory that i
was talking about before
right and uh and then there's some
method some theorems that tells us that
if the flow functions that we learn
guarantee that the amount of flow coming
in is equal to amount flow coming out of
each node
then
uh the policy that we get at the end
as i said before is going to sample from
the reward function normalized and and
that we get this
partition function
uh in the initial state flow
um
yeah so there's also some theory that
tells us that
uh if we train we can train this
particular reinforcement learning system
general model um offline so we don't
need to train it on the trajectories
that it generates itself which is often
an issue
in reinforcement learning and and other
methods like variational methods that
learn also a policy like this
but
where
they're trained on the trajectories that
they generate themselves uh which is
fine but you want to be able to explore
more and
and so these g flats can be trained
using any set of trajectories any
distribution trajectory so long as it
has uh
full support so
that gives us a handle on exploration
um and also exploiting whatever data we
have uh when we train so so in the
nearest paper we showed that this
actually
gives a nice diversity of candidates
comparing to mcmc methods and rl methods
covering more modes than we would
otherwise
um
there are some
you know interesting differences with
the the more common we've done that
right where we're trying to maximize the
work here we're trying to sample and
proportion to the reward there are some
connections to our existing rl methods
like entropy maximization methods
so
we've you know done a bunch of papers
for example this one is about improving
the way we train them this one is how do
we use data to train the energy function
the the reward function
uh this one applies these ideas in
searching for new molecules here new uh
proteins
new peptides
and now in the last few minutes let's
let me talk about the causality aspect
so
so up to now i've
i've mostly covered sort of the
experimental design part
how we can train a policy that samples
new candidate experiments maybe that
maximizes some kind of expected
information again
but the same tools that i've been
talking about
can be used to
sample from the bayesian posterior over
things we care about
like
the causal structure
that may explain the data
and
i don't have time to give you a
lecture on causality but one of the big
questions
in
causal machine learning is
given some data set and even sometimes
an infinite data set there may be many
causal graphs that indicate you know
which variable is is the cause of what
variable
direct cost that are compatible with the
data
um and so what what i'd like to put
forward is that
the
better way of dealing with this
ambiguity is to estimate the bayesian
posterior over these graphs or over the
models more generally
because that will tell us about in a way
implicitly because we typically cannot
enumerate them all the graphs that are
compatible with the data so in the
scientific cases i said this is really
important
for two reasons one is it helps us get a
handle on
the uncertainty so maybe there are
different these graphs are like
different hypotheses to explain the data
and we need to know that there are some
some ambiguity in order to design the
right experiments that reduce that
ambiguity so that's one reason the other
reason is just purely scientific like if
if you're a scientist and then there are
two different hypotheses two different
theories that explain the data you
really want to know about it uh you
don't want to just put you know all your
money on one theory and then
assume that it's correct and build the
bridge and it's the wrong theory and the
bridge falls down
so so this is super important um
okay i talked a little about
um
information gain uh sorry i'm going a
bit faster
um we we have this other paper uh next
week at uai on using gflo that's
precisely for this purpose so
estimating a bayesian posterior or for
causal grafts or over
bayesian nets
underlying graphs
i'm not going to go to the details of
this but let me let me uh just make a
little connection
to explain why the same methods the
g-floor nets can be used to get a
bayesian posterior well if you
if you remember
something from uh the basics of like
bayes theorem
the
probability of
the some latent variable like here maybe
uh
z could be
some some unobserved variables and also
some unknown parameters theta so the
posterior probability given the data we
have
the posterior probability of these
unknown quantities given the data that
we have
is proportional to the
prior on these things
times the likelihood of these things
um and
there's of course a normalizing constant
that gives you the actual probability
but
it turns out that um to train
a genetic model that will sample from
that posterior we don't need that
normalizing constant we just need to
have this normalized
reward by using the equation that
encapsulates the
both the prior on on the parameters and
the latents and the
your your your uh uh probability of
generating the data that you observe
given those parameters in those dates
um so so so there you go right there is
something you can compute based on the
data that gives you reward for different
hypotheses different models
and then we can train
our
model that generates
the possible explanations
using this reward function now there's a
slight little problem here which is that
this reward is kind of expensive to
compute because it includes a sum over
all the examples we have but it turns
out you can you can write down a
stochastic gradient version of this
that's unbiased and that allows you to
train the the generator model like the
g-flat net in um
in a
mini batch way or you know using sgds
um
okay i think i will stop there
i will put a link to this tutorial if
you want to learn more about g-formats
um
tinyurl.com
tutorial
and i will answer more questions
umar asks can g flats work in continuous
state spaces yes so the the original
paper um does everything in a discrete
space um
in one of the papers we show
mathematically that it's fairly
straightforward in principle to do that
on continuous spaces
and i don't think there are any papers
right now using continuous state
g flow ethonets but we've done
experiments and
and it works but this is something to
explore more
um
let's see muhammad asks
can we make the graph bi-directional and
solve for non-iid problems
okay so i guess
why am i you're talking about the column
graph
i'm not sure what you're talking about
actually
um
how is that related to
um
non-idness
in in causality which i didn't really
have time to cover here this is the side
thing
um
you could have
directed
causal graphs
where you know a causes b but b doesn't
cause a but you could also have
graphs with loops if you want a causes b
and b causes a like voltage and current
and in that case uh you know you need
different tools for doing that you need
the tools of
equilibrium systems so think about like
what's really going on with voltage and
current is that you have electrons that
really follow you know
time
oriented causality
um
but we're not modeling the phenomenon
that level we're we're like looking at
the
stationary distribution you know if i
perturb the voltage the current is going
to change but it's going to change
through
some you know differential equations
and that converge to some place and
that's where at that place we see
that after intervening on the current
voltage change or vice versa
now the eye idenas is something really
interesting and important about
causality that it's actually a great
theoretical tool to deal with the fact
that
there are changes in distribution that
the data is not iid
so non-iodine is like throws off a lot
of machine learning and there's a lot of
research in machine learning about
things like you know how
how do you generalize out of
distribution how do you deal with the
new tasks new environments so the iid
assumption is violated
and uh and the causal framework is
actually a very
nice and clean way to
in principle deal with that and then
incorporate those potential changes as
interventions in the cosmograph
okay um
shu ishida is asking
how scalable is g flow net
it's scaled to problems with very long
time horizons with a large branching
factor
um that's a good question
and i don't know the answer so we we
have explored that a bit the first paper
had very short sequences like you know
10 steps
we've moved on to larger sequences of
like hundreds um
and
we've explored
training objectives that are better
suited to longer sequences so that
but it's actually a very similar problem
that you have in reinforcement learning
when
you have very long trajectories and you
only get a reward at the end
and if you use temporal difference it's
like the credit assignment has to go
through many many examples for like this
bootstrap process to get the information
back to the initial
parts of the trajectory
um and so the initial training
framework that we had in the first paper
was very similar to temporal difference
in rl
uh and in in more recent papers we've
used methods like
trajectory balance that i mentioned
uh that seem much more robust to longer
sequences but like we haven't tried
things like thousands or something
now i want to make us here a connection
to human
reasoning which
may be
a motivation which was
still a motivation for these types of
methods
um so when we reason we generate we
imagine solutions to problems we imagine
candidate explanations candidate
theories candidate
you know
all kinds of things
and we do it in a sequential way so the
the
at the conscious level we go through uh
a sequence of thoughts each of them is
like little addition to the previous one
and um and so the number of steps that
our mind is able to handle in this way
is actually pretty small
uh it's hard for human brains to create
thoughts that involve
thousands of steps except if
we like break it down into small parts
like we write a book you write a paper
um but you you know you
at any moment you only look at a very
small subset so there's a question of
very interesting questions about how
humans manage to do that by using some
some kind of
particle representation where we don't
think of like
the paper i'm going to write as like one
long sequence but i think of it oh i'm
going to break it down into the intro
part and the
method part and the related works and
the experimental results and then you
know now i can like focus on each of
these parts separately
so so that's one of the directions we're
looking at and i think that's what might
work for like really
long horizons
um as far as the branching factor i'm
not afraid because if you think about
the continuous case it's an infinite
branching factor so that's not really a
big issue so long as you have a way to
efficiently sample
okay another question from
tian pay
do we need to know all variables x
beforehand
okay so it depends what you're talking
about so in the experimental design
setup
x was a description of an experiment so
it must be something that's
meaningful um because well you know
somebody is going to do the experiment
or maybe some robots is going to do the
experiment so the meaning of x
needs to be known because it's something
in the real world
but
in the modeling aspects like in when i
talked about causality
well obviously there are things in the
world that we don't observe
and we create you know there's a lot of
work in machine learning for decades
on models with latent representations
and latent variables
and we don't know what these should be
ahead of time and so this
this is also something you could do uh
with the methods i described um
in particular in causality like a very
important question is
some of the causes are not directly
observed you observed outcomes maybe to
give an example coming again from
biology you observe images of cells
and you don't actually see you know the
causes interacting with each other
directly you only have some
some view on that which is given by
these images right so so this is this is
an important like research direction
that
[Music]
you know there's some work but i think
we need a lot more work in that
direction
um
so probably models with with latent
variables in general this this is hard
but like super important we have to make
progress on these things
um andrea is asking now um
does the approach consider the relevance
of the information gained
that's a great question um he says
it might be the case that some
information might be more available than
other types of information yes
absolutely so going back to biology you
know maybe there are lots of things
going on in those cells and be great to
figure out all the you know causal
structure
um but you know it's 20 000 genes that
interact with each other it's very
complicated maybe we only try to kill
the cell because it's a cancer cell and
so there's like this one part of the
state which we really care about and so
when we compute the information gain we
can compute the information gain with
respect to those random variables we
care about
we don't need to compute the efficient
information gain on like everything we
don't know but only some of the things
we don't know
so
that's feasible yes and that's indeed
important
um
samuel is asking is the flow concept
behind oops
behind g florinets inspired by
neuroscience in some way
um
no neuroscience i mean the flow concept
is something that was inspired by
flow networks that's something like in
operations research
and um
and to some extent the
dynamic programming like you find in
temporal difference methods in our
but there are connections to
neuroscience as well
um that i want to have time to describe
today
um
and before i forget let me um
let me do the
paste
of the url as i promised
okay so um
i'm i'm putting it on the chat which i
guess you don't you guys don't see but
someone a good person is going to make
it available to everyone
um
okay so now let me go to the next
question uh anonymous
do g flow nets leverage continuous
rewards uh yes the reward of course is
generally continuous
could we learn a better reward function
or it it needs to be known what is a
trade-off this is a this is a great
question so one of the papers
i mentioned was uh learning the reward
function from data
so
uh
yeah i'm not i don't have time to go
into details but there are like two
basic ways you can do it you can do it
by maximum likelihood which is what we
did about paper
and you could do it in the bayesian way
and in both cases you can reduce the
problem to things we know about and we
uh so i actually talked a little bit in
my presentation about the bayesian like
if you make the parameters actually
things you simple
in the g-format then
you are kind of learning those
parameters but not learning just one
value of the parameters you're learning
a distribution over them
all right
what is the trade-off well there's no
trade-off it's it's something we need to
do
and there are people are starting to
explore how to do these things all right
ricardo is asking can we use these
techniques to perform pure exploration
in the policy space
on a planning problem
in this case we would like the graph to
represent a deterministic policy
does this make sense well
maybe but i i'm not sure i'm completely
like understanding what you have in mind
uh let's see um
so so clearly a lot of what i've talked
about is motivated by you know how do we
do exploration
um
and
uh so i talked about information gain
and how the things that
you can get with defaults or other
methods like directional methods or mcmc
methods can tell you
um
about you know how to estimate that
information game
uh in other words where
you know what should be the reward for
exploration
um oh i see nadine is coming up so that
means it's the end three more minutes
okay uh so let me try to go quickly to
other questions uh so shu ishita is
asking in terms of hierarchical planning
what do you think are some promising
ways of automatically identifying key
states and constructing the sarc
um
well
that's a great question and uh you know
i have some thoughts about this i don't
think they're sufficiently well-formed
to share today but this is something we
do care a lot about
and i think uh you know there's also a
lot of inspiration you can take from
existing methods in article enforcement
learning
um
but um you know there's there's really
the question of how do you
break a
policy at the low level into uh the
composition of simpler sub policies
scales sometimes it's their code so this
is this is something really interesting
that
we need to work on
next one what are the main challenges
your vision when transitioning from
simulated data machine learning for
scientific discovery to real-world
interaction well we we are doing it in
the real world um and there are some
challenges the challenges are typically
things like
experiments and we will take more time
than you thought
and you need to to like really spend a
lot of time with the people who are
experts in the field to understand those
experiments you know what they mean what
are the axes so you can represent that
information properly in machine learning
setup so it's very multidisciplinary
once you get there
[Music]
next one given initial models that could
be easy from this to generate new model
states that generalize to different data
sets i'm not sure i understand that but
but if you go with a causal approach
that's the whole point is to generalize
to different data sets by thinking of
the model is telling you what would
happen if i were to make an intervention
that brings you to a different
distribution okay i'm gonna stop here
uh sorry for the questions i couldn't
answer
thank you that was that was a great i
mean we were one or two left thank you
so much for a great lecture joshua and
thank you all for attending
[Music]
you